we all saw on the movie The Matrix where
do you simply Jack in a program into our
brain and bingo we are karate masters
bingo we know how to drive a helicopter
can we do that now or maybe in the near
future and the answer is probably not
because the brain is not really a
computer it doesn't process digital
information our brain is a learning
machine it learns by itself to correct
its previous mistakes while your laptop
today is just as stupid today as it was
yesterday your laptop doesn't learn our
brain has no windows it has no software
it has no programming but it simply
learns tasks as it goes along
therefore the interface between digital
information and memory is quite
complicated these are in some sense two
operating systems so eventually we may
master that ability but we have to
reverse-engineer the brain and that's
going to take many decades so don't
expect to become a karate master anytime
soon by simply pushing a button